STEVE BALLMER:
This is Steve Ballmer. He was the
CEO of Microsoft between 2000 and 2014 which gave
him a net worth of $112 billion. Seeing this,
you’d probably be inclined to think that
Steve was one of the most respected tech
executives of all time but it’s actually quite
the opposite. In fact, aside from actual frauds
and incompetent leaders, Steve Ballmer is often
viewed as the worst big tech CEO of all time,
and many attribute his wealth to nothing
more than dumb luck. Why you ask? Well,
for starters, Microsoft stock fell 36% under
his leadership which translates to a market
cap loss of roughly $100 billion itself. This
was largely due to Microsoft screwing up with
smartphones and Windows 8 under his leadership.
In fact, the stock actually started rallying when
Steve Ballmer announced his exit. But, even more
than stock performance, much of the tech community
simply viewed Ballmer as a meme. There were all
these these infamous clips of him laughing at the
iPhone and going absolutely crazy on stage.
But, if we look past these funny clips and
his goofy personality, we’ll see that Steve was
much more than just a tech executive. For Steve,
Microsoft wasn’t just a company that he led, it
was a company that he bled. He was fiercely loyal
to everything Microsoft as he truly loved
the company. He thought that Microsoft was
hands down the best company in the world and that
everyone should use everything Microsoft. In fact,
he would eventually go on to buy the Clippers
and he would force all of the players to ditch
their iPads and iPhones. You could say that he
was basically the Louis Litt of Microsoft. But,
it wasn’t just loyalty that Steve had going for
him. Fundamentally speaking, he actually did a
pretty good job. In fact, under his leadership,
Microsoft’s revenues and profits more than
tripled. Of course, this was never reflected in
the stock price, but that’s not something that he
has control over. So, was Steve Ballmer actually
just an enthusiastic dud who got luck beyond
belief or was he just a misunderstood leader who
more than deserved his $112 billion compensation?
NEAR MISS:
Microsoft’s $100 billion bet on Ballmer
is no doubt controversial but another $100 billion
bet that’s not controversial is their investment
in cash equivalents and short term investments or
mostly bonds. If you’re not familiar with bonds,
it’s a way to lend money to the top corporations
and governments in the world. These institutions
will then turn around and use your money to
fund expansion efforts, launch new products,
and grow their profits. And in return for helping
them with their expansion, these institutions will
pay you back with interest. Traditionally, bond
investing is seen as something that conservative
old people do to protect their savings. But,
thanks to the high interest rate environment,
bonds are paying higher yields than ever. In fact,
1 year Bills from the US government are currently
yielding 5.5% and 10 year notes from the US
government are currently yielding 4.7%. If you’d
like to take advantage of these high interest
rates and lock in high yields for yourself,
please consider checking out our upcoming bond
investing app Silo in the description below. But,
anyway, getting back to Steve Ballmer, the story
of Steve actually goes all the way back to the
1970s to the dorm rooms of Harvard. Maybe, you’ve
wondered what it would be like to know someone
like Bill Gates or Steve Jobs before they were
famous in school or college. Well, luckily for
Ballmer, that’s exactly what would happen as he
would end up as across the hall from Bill Gates at
Harvard. Hearing this, you’re probably thinking:
oh well, Bill and Steve probably founded Microsoft
together. That must be why Steve got so ruch
but that’s not how things played out. You see,
Steve was from a relatively conservative immigrant
family who very much valued the stability of a
college degree and a 9 to 5 job. So, dropping out
of Harvard to bet it all on a software company
with Bill wasn’t exactly Steve’s cup of tea.
So, when Bill dropped out, Steve would simply
wish him good luck and farewell and stick with
Harvard. He would eventually graduate magna cum
laude with a degree in applied mathematics and
economics in 1977. And he followed this up with
a traditional job as an assistant product manager
at Proctor & Gamble. As far as the general public
was concerned, Steve had done it. He had a degree
from Harvard and a stable job at a legacy giant
but Steve couldn’t help but feel that something
was missing. Maybe it was the monotony of a 9 to 5
or the lack of creativity, he couldn’t tell but he
was determined to find out. In fact, he would turn
around and try to break into hollywood by writing
screenplays in his free time. Unfortunately,
this never went anywhere and Steve would find
himself lost once again. He figured that maybe
returning to school would help him, so he would
enroll in a graduate program at Stanford. But,
it wasn’t until Steve got a call from Bill that
he would finally find his path. At the time,
Microsoft was filled with a bunch of extremely
smart tech dudes but what they didn’t have was
a business dude. And as the company grew larger
and started have more meetings and negotiations,
this became increasingly apparent. Microsoft
needed a business leader so Bill would call
up his friend from Harvard: Steve Ballmer. This
time, Steve wasn’t hesitant. After all, he had
nothing to lose. He already had a degree and real
world experience, so if Microsoft didn’t work out,
he could always just get another job or return
to Stanford. In fact, when Steve told his mom
about his plan to join Microsoft she said quote
“OK, OK, we hear you, but if it doesn’t work out,
you’ll go back to business school right?” Steve
replied “right” but he would never come back.
PROVING HIS WORTH:
Steve’s initial salary
was quite modest, $50,000 per year but that
wasn’t the entire offer. Bill also offered
Steve 5-10% equity in the company depending on
his performance. Steve started off as basically
the scapegoat. Anything that the tech guys
didn’t want to do, Steve would handle. This
included little things like cooking and washing
bottles to setting up accounting and HR. But,
it wasn’t until later on in 1980 that Steve would
really prove his worth. You see, in July of 1980,
IBM would approach Microsoft with a deal
to make software for their new computers.
There was just one problem, Microsoft didn’t
actually have what they were looking for:
an operating system. And this is when Microsoft
would pull off one of the biggest bluffs in tech
history. Though Microsoft didn’t have their own
OS, they did know where to find one. A local
computer company called Seattle Computer Products
had an OS called QDOS which was very similar to
what IBM was looking for. So, Microsoft’s plan was
to basically get IBM to allow Microsoft to go out
and buy QDOS and modify it for IBM’s needs. But,
there was one obvious flaw with this plan. IBM
could easily just go to Seattle Computer Products
directly. So, it was up to Microsoft to convince
IBM to let them be this sort of middle man and
that’s where Steve Ballmer comes in to play. Steve
would basically become Microsoft’s sales guy with
IBM. And let me just say, Steve hit it out of the
park as this deal would basically make Microsoft.
IBM didn’t even know what was happening. In fact,
they thought that they had pulled a quick one
over on Steve and these college dropouts. You see,
Microsoft didn’t ask for as much money upfront or
a per copy royalty like IBM was expecting them to.
So, they thought they had a slam dunk deal. They
didn’t have to pay as much and Microsoft was gonna
handle all of the ground work in customizing QDOS
for IBM. And in return, all Microsoft wanted was
the ability to sell this OS to other companies,
that’s it. Without giving it a second thought,
IBM would agree to pay Microsoft $45,000 for
what would end up being MSDOS. On the surface,
Microsoft didn’t make a good deal as it would cost
them $50 to $75,000 just to acquire QDOS. But Bill
Gates very much knew what they had just pulled
off. They had basically gotten IBM to largely
pay for a new operating system that Microsoft
would own and IBM would popularize despite not
even creating the software in the first place. It
wasn’t till decades later that the general public
really began to understand what was really
at stake for Microsfot with this deal. But,
Bill knew immediately and as promised, in 1981, he
would hand over an 8% stake to the man who made it
possible: Steve Ballmer. Over the next few years,
Microsoft would follow through with their deal
with IBM and deliver to them a customized
version of QDOS called MSDOS. MSDOS would
end up being a solid success and lead to a very
successful IPO, but the real magic didn’t happen
till 1985. In 1985, Microsoft would take MSDOS,
add in a graphical user interface, and call it
Windows. And this would take MSDOS from being a
successful product to being a legendary product.
STEVE’S LEGACY:
The rest of the 1980s and 90s were pretty smooth
sailing for Steve. As Microsoft grew, so did his
wealth and title. He went from being a manager
to being an executive leading various divisions
across Microsoft including operations, sales,
OS development, and support. And all of this
climaxed when Bill Gates decided to step aside
at the turn of the century, making Steve Ballmer
the new CEO of Microsoft which brings us back to
the question of the day: did Steve Ballmer deserve
to earn $112 billion? Well, that’s hard to say
frankly because it’s hard to say that anyone truly
deserves that sum of money, but we can look at it
through a different lens. Instead of looking at
from an output perspective, we can look at it from
an input perspective. Did Steve Ballmer make an 8%
contribution to Microsoft back in 1980? Well, the
answer is absolutely. He spearheaded the deal that
not only put Microsoft on the map but literally
led to the creation of their hero product:
Windows. So, no, Steve did not just get lucky. The
only reason people even say that is because Steve
didn’t immediately take the plunge with Bill Gates
and Paul Allen in 1975. So, history has basically
painted Steve as this guy who just happened to
come in as Microsoft’s 30th employee and got an 8%
stake just because he was friends with Bill Gates.
And his goofy bubbly personality simply plays
into this persona but this really isn’t a fair
assessment. While Steve wasn’t there from day 1,
he very much played the role of being a cofounder
or atleast the role of being their first business
executive. And the IBM deal was simply his biggest
contribution. Let’s not forget that Steve also
spent 34 years as a Microsoft executive 14 of
which were as CEO. And during his stint as CEO,
Microsoft came out with some of their most iconic
products including the Xbox, Windows XP, Windows
7, and even Azure which is often quoted as being
what “saved Microsoft”. Not to mention, Steve
tripled Microsoft’s revenue and profit. Microsoft
stock not going anywhere had more to do with the
dotcom crash and the 2008 crash than it did with
anything the Steve did or didn’t do. And it was
eventually the shareholders that pushed him out
but he’s still very much loyal to Microsoft
to this day. In fact, he’s by far Microsoft’s
largest individual stakeholder retaining over half
of his original stake at 4.5%. For perspective,
that’s 5 times more than Bill Gates who only owns
0.9% of Microsoft today. So, not only did Steve
Ballmer play a crucial role in the early days
of Microsoft but there’s no question that Steve
is by far Microsoft’s most loyal executive.
In fact, he probably wouldn’t have left if
it wasn’t for shareholders pushing him out. So,
does Steve Ballmer deserve $112 billion? Well,
I can’t answer that question but what I can say
is that Steve Ballmer didn’t just get lucky. He
deserves his money just as much as any of his
centibillionaire peers and that’s why he was
paid $112 billion. If you’d like to take advantage
of high interest rates and have the government and
top companies pay you 4-7%, check out our upcoming
bond investing app Silo in the description below.